hélène buzzati stéphanie grammond à la
question gay bonsoir bonsoir bonsoir je
disais en tout début d'émission c'est un
plaidoyer poignant on a eu droit
monsieur qui
depuis le début de cette guerre gagne
haut la main la guerre des
communications d'être capable de toucher
les gens sur le sort de son peuple et on
le veut je vous fait entendre un petit
exemple
quand il est allé en disant imaginez si
les bombes tombaient à vancouver
imaginez si les bombes tombaient sur la
tour du cn imaginez si vous deviez
expliquer à vos enfants pourquoi il ya
des quartiers détruits et c'est un petit
extrait
des jeux
avec cette demande qu'il fait dans
toutes les capitales où il se rend
demain virtuellement évidemment demain
sera washington de fermer l'espace
aérien ukrainien la réponse est toujours
la même non parce que la russie
considère rsa comme une attaque directe
de l'otan hélène buzzetti est-ce que sur
le fond ça bouge pas que j'ai cessé
grandissions là mais ils continuent à
semer cet espoir-là disant j'ai besoin
de vous ai je besoin de gagner oui et
vous l'avais dit c'était très poignant
est ce que moi j'ai trouvé
particulièrement efficace et percutant
c'est sa façon qu'il a eue au président
de prendre à partie personnellement
justin trudeau le premier ministre en
disant justin imaginez si c'était vos
enfants qui se réveillait la nuit au
bruit des missiles imaginez par exemple
d'avoir à recevoir tous les jours le
bilan des décès de voir par exemple
qu'il ya eu un total de 97 enfants
jusqu'à présent des décédés il y avait
cette puissance il y avait une
communication directe en p2 homme si je
suis et ont ramené sang à un niveau très
très personnel évoquant les enfants on
sait que monsieur trudeau en a et ça
rendait le message d'autant plus
percutant mais vous avez raison on est
quand même dans le symbole ici parce que
il n'y aurait rien sur le fond qui a
changé c'est le même message qui a été
véhiculé en grande bretagne la semaine
passée qui se reprend le même aux états
unis mais vous savez ces discours à la
chambre des communes de leaders
étrangers savent souvent un objectif
politique c'était par exemple le cas en
2016 quand barack obama à la fin de son
mandat était venu nous parler c'est un
peu pour sceller cette espèce de
d'amitié leur romance entre monsieur
trudeau est lui même ou alors même 2006
année de karzaï le président afghan
afghans
sa visite était visait pas à rehausser
la popularité d'une mission canadienne
dans ce pays qui commençait à battre un
peu de lait alors il ya quelque chose de
quand même très politique là dedans ça
vient apaiser de quelconque critique qui
pourrait exister au canada par exemple
sur l'envoi d'armes là bas et c'est très
symbolique mais ça ne veut pas être
inutile et ça a permis de voir de
mesurer encore visuellement et sonore
manque même que le consensus
unanimité même l'appui
à ce pays en guerre c'est fanny
grandmont la cheffe conservatrice est
allé un peu plus loin dans devrait
pouvoir protéger des couloirs
humanitaires en ukraine mais bon sur le
fond comme dit hélène les guerriers qui
a changé
non malheureusement qui s'est fait très
déchira parce que oui on voit les gens
qui applaudissent
c'était c'était poignant de voir cette
ovation leur avec monsieur
tout le monde applaudit et puis tout le
monde se senti concerné on voit la
guerre sur nos écrans depuis depuis
vingt et un jours mais là quand elle
s'est invitée au parlement du canton
fait parallèle aussi directement avec et
imaginez si c'était au canada bien
évidemment qu'on aurait et qu'on aurait
envie d'intervenir mais le problème est
évidemment c'est que si on se on se rend
aux demandes de monsieur zelensky ben ça
va vouloir dire une escalade et dans le
contexte actuel en personne ne veut
avoir une troisième guerre mondiale où
on a un despote qui pourrait peser sur
le bouton de l'arme nucléaire donc ses
atouts puisque on re ce qu'on veut
éviter maintenant est ce que ça veut
dire qu'il y aura rien qu'on peut faire
un nom je ne pense pas les sanctions
économiques
il faut leur donner le temps de faire
leur effet c'est pas automatique sepa en
quelques jours la queue que la douleur
économique se fait ressentir
donc il ya quand même espoir que ça que
ça fasse débloquer des choses là diplôme
ainsi je sais bien que c'est pas
aujourd'hui le fonds a l'impression que
les choses débloquent mais il faut
essayer jusqu'au bout peut-être aussi
que la chine va pouvoir jouer un rôle
dans tout ça elle qui s'est présentée un
peu comme il aligner de la russie
peut-être pas changé de discours parce
que elle a aussi besoin même si c'est la
deuxième grande puissance économique du
monde et elle a quand même besoin de
l'occident des états unis de l'europe
pour faire son commerce donc si jamais
et tout ça se fait marcher les bains se
seraient pas très bons non plus pauvres
pour pour l'intérieur du pays dont la
demande
la chine est un peu un pays un géant aux
pieds d'argile parce que la demande
intérieure demeure pas très forte et
puis mais finalement c'est ça on peut on
peut quand même continuer sur ces fronts
là et sur le front d'envoyer des armes
sur le terrain au maximum pour que
monsieur elie plus se défendre au mieux
possible j'ai commencé on lui disait
alec
tenez bon lot durée puis le teint est de
votre côté parce que les russes tu
arrives pas gagné
la pression est peut-être va devenir
intenable pour poutine qui s'est alors
tenez bon mais on peut pas faire
tellement plus
non mais c'est vrai que plus la guerre
est longue plus c'est compliqué beaucoup
tino tant sur le plan militaire que sur
le plan économique quelques très cher
cette guerre là pour rob l'a dit mais
putin donc faut qu'il tienne est ce que
ces discours le change quelque chose à
court terme peut-être pas à plus long
terme certainement d'avoir sa garde
l'opinion publique mobilisée la
communication c'est une arme de guerre
aussi et c'est l'un des endroits où le
team usa lenski paires seront beaucoup
mieux que la russie ancien comédien il
ya quand même un atout à savoir
s'adresser à la caméra est capable de
manipuler les réseaux sociaux est
capable d'utiliser une caméra il le fait
très bien ça veut ça permet aux pays
occidentaux de ne pas reculer d'abord
ensuite ses parents qui demandent une
zone d'exclusion aérienne kissi très
bien ne pas pouvoir obtenir ça incite
les payer a dit bon je vais en faire
quand même un peu plus sur d'autres
fronts je vais vous envoyer un peu plus
de son je vous ai dit d'une autre
manière donc c'est la stratégie des
petits pas pour que les pays soient
capables d'en faire plus et vous voyez
ça fonctionne parce qu'ils s'adressaient
pas seulement justin trudeau aujourd'hui
volodymyr zielinski s'adresse à toute la
chambre des communes qu'est ce qui
t'arrive et le parti conservateur
au fait un pas de plus ce nom il le fait
important on devrait surveiller la zone
aérienne des couloirs humanitaires on
devrait avoir une zone d'exclusion pour
les couloirs humanitaires c'est un pas
de plus parti d'opposition il va donc
mettre la pression sur justin trudeau on
va pas se rendre à une zone d'exclusion
totale mais c'est comme ça que
tranquillement on ne va du côté des
landes ce qui cherchait un peu plus
d'appuis un peu plus de moyens et c'est
pour ceux qui parlent dès qu'il le peut
à toutes les capitales étrangères il ya
une stratégie derrière tout ça et si
j'aime vous étiez là vous êtes là encore
la chaîne conservatrice s'était donc oui
pour mettre la pression sur le
gouvernement trudeau mais c'est quand
même pas de plus le sais pas ce que ça
soit un couloir humanitaire ou pas
c'est une avancée de plus d'aviation de
l'otan
oui et non parce qu en fait j'étais très
étonnée par cette sortie de madame
bergen et j'ai demandé des précisions
sur cette idée le monde ce qu'elle a dit
c'est qu'on devrait à tout le moins
créer une zone d'exclusion aérienne
au-dessus des coqs d'or à et humanitaire
et quand j'ai demandé mais comment
feriez-vous sont en fait ce qu'ils
disent et non non on veut pas que l'otan
assure cette protection cette exclusion
un risque qu'on propose c'est l'envoi
d'avions chasseurs mig-29
comme cette transaction qui n'a pas
fonctionné on propose par exemple des
des systèmes de missiles antiaériens de
style stingers et si des choses que les
hommes les êtres humains peuvent porter
à l'épaule et abattre des avions avec ça
déjà les états unis en fournissent bref
quand on gratte un peu non les
conservateurs de ne propose pas le temps
d'aller créer des cadres de comptoir
exemple à deux ils ont l'air d'être du
côté du crâne mais dans le fond ils
suivent quand même pas mal le consensus
international
très bien vous avez raison vous l'avez
souligné le donner le nombre
il est quand je disais poignant l'acadie
à 97 enfants qui sont morts ça c'est
précis c'est dur on voit les images tout
de suite ok on change de sujet rentrée
parlementaire à québec
on va écouter madame en anglais des
monsieur legault
s'escrimer à la période des questions
sur la question des tarifs
d'hydro-québec et monsieur legault qui a
parlé avant mais je vous le fais écouter
après qu'explique qui laissera pas hydro
québec augmenté de 5 6% létard étonné
qu'au
ministre est toujours en train de
regarder en arrière incapable d'en
tisser lorsque la dame juge qui aurait
des risques qui auraient des défis
importants en matière d'inflation qu'est
ce que le premier ministre nous a dit il
a répondu monsieur le président la j'ai
invité le chef du parti libéral
d'arrêter d'exagérer enfin la chaîne
l'opposition officielle ne veut pas
regarder en arrière
pour garder l'ancien chef du parti
libéral tu veux mais un construire des
oléoducs qui vont passer au québec
monsieur le président c'est seul ancien
parti libéral je comprends qu'il soit
rex existe pas passer l'or mais monsieur
le président le parti libéral a augmenté
tarifs de plus que l'inflation
l'année prochaine si l'inflation à un
niveau exceptionnel on va remettre de
l'argent notre portefeuille
diop l'augmentation de 4 5 ou plus pour
cent des tarifs d'électricité le 1er
avril 2000 23 on va prendre les moyens
pour compenser les québécois mais il y
aura pas d'augmentation de 4 5% est ce
qu'on parle pour l'instant c'est une
aide spéciale non récurrentes pour
l'année 2022 pour couvrir l'inflation
actuelle maintenant pour les tarifs
d'électricité en 2023 et là aussi il ya
une aide qui est ponctuelle maintenant
est ce que la carte proposera des
baisses d'impôts permanentes belle le
jeu vous invite à attendre la campagne
électorale qui est pas mal là c'est
d'une certaine façon c'est fanny
grammont je commence avec vous puis
après on note rock monsieur legault
voulait faire des détours pour parler
monsieur charest absolument on ça va ça
va revenir souvent mais stéphanie sur
hydro-québec comme on l'est avec gérald
il est pris avec sa loi là il va devoir
modules et où trouver une façon pour pas
si l'inflation continue de l'an prochain
pour pas laisser trop québec galoper
avec des 5%
non mais c'est ça mais honnêtement
c'était écrit dans le ciel en 2019 quand
le quand il veut passer sa loi que ce
risque est de se retrouver dans une
situation comme celle là parce que les
coûts d'hydro-québec sont sans aucune
commune mesure avec l'inflation donc là
bas c'est ce qui fait que on se retrouve
avec des augmentations énorme alors que
ça coûte pas plus cher nécessairement à
hydro de produire donc avant il y avait
un mécanisme ça s'appelait la régie de
l'énergie et ça fonctionnait pour
essayer de dire quelle est
l'augmentation raisonnable on devrait
revenir à ça parce que c'est quand même
étrange que ce soit le premier ministre
qui décide à la pièce pour mieux les
études je tue trois tours il me semble
que c'est pas sérieux du tout là et puis
par contre moi ce que je pourrais dire
c'est qu'il ya peut-être effectivement
nul que les gens aient les mélanges fait
mouche à leur électricité si on veut
faire une pension
une pension énergétique on va avoir
besoin de beaucoup plus d'énergie
beaucoup plus d'électricité
et si on veut encourager les gens à
moins gaspiller
bien évidemment que en envoyant un
signal de pénis est un bon moyen c'est
pas en gelant les tarifs et qu'on
encourage les gens faire la meilleure
utilisation de leurs de leur énergie
alors peut-être que c'est une bonne
chose à faire mais il faudrait pas que
ça se fasse en cachette sur une couvert
de l'inflation c'est un débat de société
qu'on devrait avoir ouvertement
ouais il dit ils diront jamais alec mais
peut-être qui regrette un peu d'avoir
mis l'agent régie de l'énergie parce
qu'il y avait un mécanisme s'est
compliquée la hydro allait plaider puis
bon mais il y avait comme un mécanisme
qui étaient là comment on fait
c'était une erreur à l'époque de
modifier la manière dont on fait que ces
tarifs d'hydro-québec c'est encore plus
flagrant c'est une erreur aujourd'hui la
régie de l'énergie aie pour retirer des
mains du gouvernement l'aspect politique
le jouer avec les tarifs pour des
raisons électorales et clairement il y
avait une raison à ça et on s'en rendent
compte aujourd'hui même quand on voulait
fixer à l'inflation autour de 2%
c'était quand même deux fois plus que
les récentes arrivées drew québec annuel
que si en 0.70 0 9% il n'avait pas
besoin d'être fixé à l'inflation s'était
déjà un cadeau à hydro québec imaginez à
deux points 6 pi 4 5% et le problème
c'est que si on envoie un chèque pour
compenser le bien dit ponctuellement
mais la hausse de 4 5% elle reste et
l'année d'après on va en ajouter une
autre europe ou tchèques pour la machine
vraiment une marche
à lille ça va toujours être comme ça le
long 1 4% au maroc tchèque 3 400 bébés
coin mais la pression on ajoute un autre
2 % au 4 5% qui s'est ajoutée aux
blondes en vaut plus cher parce que
l'inflation est revenue à la normale
morgan est mal c'est un mécanisme qui
est tout croche on devrait revenir à
quelque chose de scientifique avec des
experts comme c'était le cas 20 l'acq
acq devrait dire on a fait une erreur on
n'avait pas prévu ça de l'inflation
comme celle là aurait au mécanisme
d'avant ça fait mal à la prochaine
campagne électorale mais ça serait la
bonne la bonne solution et ce serait
beaucoup plus responsable qu'il a déjà
faible sur lequel voit que l'a déjà fait
il est capable de s'excuser pizza l'on
n'avait pas pris mais sony sur elle
qu'on n'avait pas pris lui sonne trop
émue une ex est une inflation comme
celle-là même moment donné il faut aussi
en prendre acte et agir en conséquence
ouais pas sinon tu fais quoi tu fais
inflation moins 2 / 3 puis une personne
qui est la formule hockey hélène hélène
moi je veux que vous me parliez déjà
charest parce que pas de jean charest
mais monsieur legault on s'aperçoit ça
va être une longue date actes auprès de
la mangue la danza jeu charest veut
passer d aller au duc c'est votre ancien
chef
il faut en parler aujourd'hui maintenant
dans le sucre avec les journalistes dans
la mêlée de presse voulant parler ils
attendaient une question sur mon sort
mais ils veulent peut-être le regretter
parce que bon évidemment que lula c'est
très pratique parce que la prochaine
échéance c'est une échéance électorale
provinciale au québec et donc ça lui
permet évidemment évidemment de
s'attaquer aux libéraux de faire toutes
les blagues que l'on dit aujourd'hui et
qui vont se répéter assurément mais
admettons que monsieur charest devait
devenir le chef du parti conservateur et
au mont vert bien l'homme est d'abord
hybride il va être choisi en plein
milieu de la campagne provinciale en
passant est mon l'a vu dans le passé la
caq souhaité l'élection d'un
gouvernement conservateur à ottawa
c'est ce qui l'a pris comme position
dans la dernière campagne provinciale il
ya des affinités idéologiques entre la
cac et incertain une certaine frange
antico du parti conservateur fédéral et
donc si monsieur charest devait devenir
chef et que l'eau tout d'un coup
monsieur legault pourrait vouloir
souhaité son élection et baloyi il
serait pris avec 18 des rations pas
sigle barbare qui la bat as he et
beaucoup week end xt plater il y à des
scénarios intéressants
mais on n'est pas là comme vous dites ça
commence la course chez les
conservateurs on verra avec un petit mot
là dessus sur ce désir de monsieur
legault dont envoyer une petite monsieur
charest
est pris en empêcher mais c'est de bonne
guerre aussi sadique et jean charest à 1
une image dans l'opinion publique les
gens ont une opinion lui puis elle est
passablement négative je parie sur l'art
faire
pour ça alors on sauve sur l'image
négative qui reste de jean charest n'a
la population pour attaquer un peu le
parti libéral
tant qu'à six mois des élections
on verra si la régie 202 de l'énergie va
renaître de ses cendres et l'aisne c'est
fanny alec merci beaucoup nous avons
parlé ce soir salut au revoir mois
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne ici et redit